hay 400 61 hogares en la parte de la
ciudad donde vive samuel él contó que
352 de esos hogares son departamentos
cuántos de esos hogares no son
departamentos como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta muy bien vamos a resolverlos
juntos
comenzamos con 461 hogares y queremos
saber cuántos de esos no son
departamentos tenemos que restar el
número de los que sí son departamentos y
nos dicen que 352 de esos hogares son
departamentos por lo que restamos el
número de los departamentos y quedará el
número de los que no son departamentos
así que sólo tenemos que evaluar 461
menos 352 y como ya comentamos en otros
vídeos hay varias técnicas para hacer
esto podemos descomponer 352 en sus
diferentes valores posicionales podemos
decir que esto es lo mismo que 461 menos
cambiamos de color
tres centenas o trescientos menos cinco
decenas o cincuenta y menos dos y ahora
deberían poder calcular esto 461 menos
trescientos va a ser igual a sólo
quitamos tres centenas a esto lo que da
161 si a esto le restamos 50 cuánto es
61 menos 50 es 11 por lo que 161 menos
50 va a ser 111 otra forma de pensar en
esto es que si tomamos 5 decenas de
estas seis decenas nos queda una decena
es una centena una decena y una unidad
que da 111 y por último pero no menos
importante queremos restar este 211
menos dos es 9 por lo que 111 menos 2 es
109 como mencioné antes existen varias
formas de abordar esto quizá piensen que
es más fácil restar 350 en lugar de 352
para hacerlo restamos 2 en ambos números
si restamos 1 a 461 que da 460 y si
restamos 2 queda 459 a 459 le restamos
350 todo esto viene de la idea de que la
diferencia no cambia siempre y cuando se
sume o se reste la misma cantidad en
ambos números aquí podemos decir que 4
centenas menos tres centenas es una
centena y 59 menos 50 es igual a 9 esto
da el mismo resultado tomen nota de que
esto se trata acerca de restar 352 a 461
y de que hay varias maneras de hacerlo